just 24 hours ago this country stood on
the brink of Cataclysm after weeks of
slow escalation and without a single
vote from the Congress the United States
came within minutes of war with Iran in
response to the destruction of an
unmanned drone American forces nearly
launched an airstrike on Iranian targets
according to some reports our planes
were literally in the air but in the end
it didn't happen the president pulled
back this morning he explained why they
came and they said sir we're ready to go
we'd like a decision I said I want to
know something before you go how many
people will be killed in this case
Iranians I said how many people are
going to be killed sir I'd like to get
back to you on that great people these
generals they said came back said sir
approximately 150 and I thought about it
for a second I said you know what they
shut down an unmanned drone plane
whatever you want to call it
and here we are sitting with 150 dead
people that would have taken place
probably within a half an hour after I
said go ahead and I didn't like it I
didn't think it was I didn't think it
was proportionate how many people will
be killed the most basic of all
questions but a question that's too
rarely asked by leaders contemplating
war a hundred and fifty people wiped off
the planet in retaliation for a broken
drone every one of them the president
reminded his staff last night someone
with a family the whole thing in the end
offended his sense of decency he said it
seemed disproportionate and it was more
over air strikes would have led to a
wider conflict with Iran that of course
was the entire point of it policymakers
in Washington crave a war with Iran last
night was supposed to be the first
domino at the last minute the president
warded their plans for that he's being
vilified watch CNN's thirty six-year-old
national security analyst attack the
president for not killing enough people
yesterday this is kind of a worst-case
scenario the president is showing that
he's dense we made a decision had a
National Security Council meeting and
wasn't willing to follow through all in
all this shows grossed
organization and a president who can't
seem to make up his mind even on
something as important it's a military
strike on Iran only in foreign policy
circles do people say things that's
stupid in fact last night was a high
point in the Trump presidency
bombing Iran would have ended his
political career in a minute there'd be
no chance of reelection after that
ill-advised Wars are like doing cocaine
the initial rush Rises your poll numbers
but the crash is inevitable in this case
it would be horrible the hangover from
an Iraq war with last year's Iran is not
Syria or Iraq it's a big rich
sophisticated country with an ancient
culture and a cohesive population in
some ways it's an impressive place not
at all like the chintzy prefab capitals
of the Arab world like Riyadh or Dubai
we could beat Iran but it would not be
easy it would cost trillions of dollars
many thousands of Americans likely would
die
China would love it they'd be the only
winners in that conflict Donald Trump
was elected president precisely to keep
us out of disasters like war with Iran
so how did we get so close to starting
one simple the neo-cons still wield
enormous power in Washington they don't
care what the cost of a war with Iran is
they certainly don't care what the
effect on Trump's political fortunes
might be they despise Donald Trump now
one of their key allies is the national
security adviser of the United States
John Bolton is an old friend of Bill
crystals together they helped plan the
Iraq war when Bouldin made it to the
White House the neocons cheered
left-wing New York Times columnist Brett
Stevens took a break from attacking
Donald Trump to celebrate his hiring
Stevens assured MSNBC viewers that John
Bolton was a great choice because he
would push the president toward war he
is not the sort of caricature ich hawk
that he's been made out to be in some in
some corners of the press I think
someone like Bolton is going to restrain
the isolationist impulses that have been
really at the heart of Trump's foreign
policy thinking got that John Bolton is
going to restrain Donald Trump from
avoiding war and of course that's
exactly what he's tried to do from the
very first day
Charlie before Bolton took his new job
we invited him on this show and asked
about some of his many many previous
foreign policy positions
watch as Bolton denies ever being wrong
ever about anything not even a little
bit so you've you've called for regime
change in Iraq Libya Iran and Syria in
the first two countries we've had regime
change and obviously it's been I'd say a
disaster I think now no I don't agree
with that and let me let me I don't
think it's been a disaster no I think
you need to understand yeah is that life
is complicated the Middle East and when
you say well the overthrow of Saddam
Hussein was a mistake is simplest I
would argue that I'm the one who
understands how complicated it is but
just my view it's it's your long
experience in foreign policy no better
record than yours I would say got that
Hillary Clinton's toppling of the Libyan
government was not a disaster says John
Bolton keep in mind there are literally
slave markets operating in the streets
of Tripoli right now no problem though
Bolton's fine with that he's fine with
the outcome in Iraq - that wasn't a
disaster either according to John Bolton
it was a raging success we killed
hundreds of thousands of people lost
thousands of our own troops spent more
than a trillion dollars all to eliminate
a WMD threat that despite John Boehner's
assurances never existed in the first
place Bolton is glad we did all that
really happy about it that's demented
normal people don't talk like that
there's nothing normal about John Bolton
check out this piece of tape recently
uncovered in which Bolton promises that
we're going to overthrow the government
of Iran keep in mind that this was
filmed long before the Iranians shot
down a single drum I had said for over
10 years since coming to these events
that the declared policy of the United
States of America should be the
overthrow of the mullahs regime in
Tehran
and that's why before 2019 we here will
celebrate in Tehran thank you very much
in other words last night has been in
the works for years john bolton is a
kind of bureaucratic tapeworm try as you
might you can't expel him he seems to
live forever in the bowels of the
federal agencies periodically
re-emerging to cause pain and suffering
but critically somehow never suffering
himself his life really is Washington in
a nutshell blunder into obvious
catastrophes again and again refused to
admit blame and then demand more of the
same that's the John Bolton life cycle
in between Administration jobs are
always cushy think-tank posts paid
speaking gigs cable news contracts war
may be a disaster for America but for
John Bolton and his fellow neo-cons it
is always good business